[Musik]
so ist das hätte das ganze aussehen das
haben wir alles dauert wirklich alle
zeichnete selber gemacht dass wir immer
alles gut
das ist völliger
chronik geht's römer
ohne hirt nick würde es wohl keine
sparlampe geben aber jetzt hat sich
seine welt verdunkelt der erfinder
verlor sein vermögen an internetbetrüger
das cnnic tag mache die zimmer denkt was
hält man richtig machen so selten falsch
macht bleibe ich
short habe
das ist aber so dass nur sechs schafen
und das wunderbare sache nach studiert
was ist eine falsch gelaufen
wie gutgläubige betrogen werden und
deswegen alles verlieren davon handelt
diese reportage
[Musik]
es war vor zehn jahren als wir hier
nicht zum ersten mal in seiner werkstatt
in zürich trafen
die armierung
das
kreativhaus hans-lothar drehen ja
schließlich alles raus
-rufe bruch mit als zu wenig
entwickelt immer haus
[Musik]
inmitten seines durcheinanders von
kabeln und geräten hat er schon manches
erfunden unter anderem entwickelte der
tüftler die elektronik der
energiesparlampe
das wie zwar ist das braucht sich
niemand dass das ein schweizerisch
aber über 8000 weniger ist es trainer
hört man selbst gebrauchte dinge dass
noch weh dass sie die anna harnik gar
nicht an
ich weiß es macht ja
in seinem kleinen betrieb entstanden
rund 80 erfindungen die alle ein patent
erhielten
das ist das einfachste meter das ist es
hier richtig wohl auch selber baut das
ist für toner das sind blitz kann
übrigens nicht wissen da könnte man
blitz vor während sie das der motor
entwickelt
das ist drehte das ist ein mitarbeiter
herr witz und er macht jetzt der test ob
das
funktioniert doch
noch heute im alter von 88 jahren
tüftelt er an erfindungen herum wie
immer bleibt er dabei seiner philosophie
treu den menschen ein besseres leben zu
ermöglichen
wo bist du bist was du kennt das nicht
jeden tag
in afrika und in jemen und das heißt man
etwas macht die wäsche ist jetzt drei
jahr bereit aber ich habe es jetzt kein
sponsor gefunden
und die flächen so gemacht dass wir auch
an anderen autobatterie haben wir die
anschlüsse fähre 20 12 volt und dann
muss die lampen der in hannover lampe
die brend und dort sämtliche viren und
bakterien aus dem wasser zu 1,9 prozent
erholen so dass das wasser trinkbar ist
dass sich hinter nicht noch krank werden
und jeden tag ein virtuose krebs der die
da müsste man ja in afrika forster recht
rom zugang hat das ist was ist das da
geht es für mögliche möglichkeit der man
muss überlegen das in afrika
viele sehr einfach ist also was sie die
person erzähler heinz nicht wenn sei die
hände der künste ist ein erzähler der
hausschlüssel und der funktioniert wenn
es das nicht entsagen events das nicht
kennt der schönste lohn und wähler nach
linie generator ruft gepäckträger tour
der generator die stehen günstig und der
fans stehen twens wähler aufstellt
verkehr blockierten könnte damit
mittäter die energie mache der braucht
nur 18 watt der b 10 minuten trends
anderthalb liter trinkwasser
weil blick auf herkömmlichem weg keine
sponsoren fand versuchte er sein glück
im internet
gerne verschiedene jörg schreiber und
probiert den hentig seit mehr machen mit
aber sie machen das portal vorleistung
leichter und da natürlich mit denen sich
unterstützer aus sponsoring ich habe das
gemacht hat total hohen dafür verdacht
du sich franke verloren sind praktisch
nur geeignete die haben immer
nachzahlung verlangt hier habe ich
plötzlich oxfam england das sage ich
jetzt auch volkswagen einer großen firma
deren vertrag geschickt wo ich nun 170
franken für die sponsoren haben wir dass
der glaube patrick franke verrußt war
dafür vertragserfüllung und alles das
ich überlegen welche bank gange gerade
das geld
heute weiß er dass es sich um gefälschte
dokumente handelt mit dem logo der
hilfsorganisation oxfam als eher
misstrauisch wurde stellte nick die
zahlungen ein seither wird er von einer
person mit den decknamen bischof bedroht
der einzige weg um ihr leben zu retten
besteht darin das zu tun was ich von
ihnen verlange
sie georg und attackierte frau und bruno
werden bei einem autounfall sterben und
wo immer sie sind es wird nichts sie
unglück sein dass ihnen folgen wird und
rom sowie
chronik erstattete anzeige doch von den
tätern fehlt bis heute jede spur
internet straftaten nehmen laufen zu im
vergangenen jahr gab es in der schweiz
24.000 solcher delikte das sind 6
prozent aller straftaten michlmayr cyber
experte bei der kantonspolizei baselland
betont dass die kriminellen weltweit
operieren sie zu fassen sei nicht
einfach die zusammenarbeit zwischen
europol und interpol bezeichnet er
grundsätzlich als gut in der schweiz
indes besteht nachholbedarf
gibt verschiedenste handlungsbedarf zum
1 auf nationaler ebene sich
gemeinsam mit der bank während aktuell
noch gemeinsam mit der bank liege das
delikt und die anderen konnten waren
froh genauso delikten dann machen wir
daraus via e mail ich liebe das e mail
aus 28 kontrolliert und den zug kommt
wurde das ist 20 21 und behüte so
effektiv bis es eine gemeinsame
datenbank gibt kann es noch ja dauern
yannick hat besuch erhalten user aus dem
liechtenstein ist ebenfalls ein erfinder
auch er wurde mehrfach opfer von
internet-betrügern
und so immer die sein klient fürstin im
ritual trophy ist der persönliche kenner
klandt und der herr bischof
vermutlich ist in afrika ich weiß es
nicht halb so viel geld verloren hat
dann der bischof hat gesagt insgesamt
also irgendwo
zwischen 60 und 80 tausend franken
hier will ich das 50 das sind verträge
um eine story aber im prinzip ja der
sinn macht ihr
verscherbelt da gibt es gar nicht nach
kitzen vermutlich mit
bruno fuß unglück begann mit der
hoffnung geld für ein startup produkt zu
erhalten
er erfand den basta barolo automaten
sein prototyp steht nun in einem
container irgendwo bei einem bauern
oberhalb des rheintals
der kochdienst sekunden al dente posten
und zwar ist ein normaler
arbeiter passte wo sie durch spezifische
sehr einfach gepasst die hauptpreise
paste wird in dosierter vor dosiert und
er wird ihr passt europas der korinther
in kisten und kästen
papiere 50 sekunden
und unter druck und dann ist der pastor
bissfest schluss kommen wäre sebastian
hueber und dann
kam es mit einem löffel
der heute 60-jährige war inhaber von
zwei firmen im bereich maschinen- und
anlagebau bruno foose hatte fünf
angestellte heute sitzt er auf einem
schuldenberg in millionenhöhe und lebt
von der fürsorge also das ist wie honig
paul iby
das ist sozial honig warum jetzt zur
verfügung gestellt hat zum glück relativ
groß sie halbwegs mit dieser können
unterbringen das ist das wo noch übrig
bleiben ist ein ganzer
privatvermögen
elektronikkomponenten
bloß der stuhl und das und der couch
das dauert ein test dass ich viel kraft
dort
baby der welt
das team mir ein keks sehen viel kraft
treten und bis jetzt so viel kraft geben
oder marke
ergänzt nichts ruft er zum weitermachen
das ist so miene blättert er vor teams
wie eine torte zieht obwohl maschinenbau
und aller gebotener super job fern ist
und die bieter entscheiden sondern mich
start up your problem gemacht stromlos
lösung sei das kapital gleich also anja
alternative
schlussendlich auf die internet-betrüger
ball um den passte automaten in serie
herstellen zu können suchte er
investoren nebst dem angebot von bischof
erhielt er noch zahlreiche weitere in
der höhe von bis zu 60 millionen franken
das ist zum beispiel ist wohl schon
selber 2017 läuft also scheint
erstaunlich dass die betrügereien mit
dem jetzt dass ich ganz aktuelle schon
sechzehnte
220 hier konnte sich vor denn sie möchte
schrieb war ja wohl gerichte
15,8 millionen pfund könnte ist wohl nur
4000 zahle den contender dokument das
ist nur eins da wo du warst du lange
tantiemen galt das ist ein thema das
geld frage wird oder c sich das über
nordwest bank kläffer und dann ist es
über jetzt lauf zur bank of england und
die die
zerfahren wurde aufgrund von mail bosco
nicht weiß mit fixer betrug ist weil es
kunden von bangkok
die vermeintlichen geldgeber setzten
alles in bewegung um bruno fußes
vertrauen zu gewinnen
sie luden ihn zu mehreren treffen ein
zum teil bin ja die ort fahrer vor ihm
berlin/london
aber im endeffekt selbst von rockcity
von mika kapitalgeber januar leistungen
unserer vertreter ja nicht drauf
was sind das für sie
ja das sind lücke wo
jegliches alte frau am kreuz und quer
assist schmidts ist mit denke mir es ist
nicht gut aber gleich ist es den
komisch dass man wenn man da holt man
sie zuerst geld bringen dass man über
gold
die welt hat sieht ein verlor insgesamt
drei millionen privat folge verloren
meine firma der firma dazu erzählt sie
immer über fünf millionen und da im
moment noch über zwei millionen schulde
ihm große ganze aber wie zuvor
so nachhinein natürlich nie fordern aber
solange das etwa
chronisch und übernehmer wieder beteuert
tore nicht mal das ist dass es stimmt
also schwarzgurt unterwelt
anwaltskanzleien kontaktieren der über
sich sein verhalten und trägt auch er
reichte strafanzeige ein die behörden
nehmen keine stellung das verfahren sei
noch nicht abgeschlossen
bruno fischer marc gutgläubig seien aber
internet betrüger sind mit allen wassern
gewaschen das ist neu die täterschaft
die gott gezielt wohl und die tut sich
entsprechend den opfern passen und
verkaufte ihnen eigentlich da wo das
gefühl hatte ich gut also die sind zum
teil sehr schätzt unterwegs und doch
haben wir wirklich damit sehr sensibel
trigger also die beiden erfinder die
hand dokumente von banken als sehr
seriös gerät aus london und dubai am
glücklichsten tag
das ist ja heute mit der technologie
sehr einfach möglich denn dass man also
urkunden
photoshop je nach dem sehr gut und
einfacher fälscher und den anschein
erweckt sich richtig gut kunde
vor zehn jahren war jörg nick ein
erfolgreicher geschäftsmann der in der
ganzen welt herumreist
in sri lanka ließ er die adapter für
seine sparlampen produzieren
auch leistete er sich safari ferien aber
selbst im dschungel konnte der quirlige
erfinder nicht richtig abschalten
wir sehr froh wenn du unter helfen
könntet ein adapter ändere das war was
ist unser zweiter dazu nimmt ihr gerät
aber das böse
in seinem betrieb beschäftigte er damals
fünf angestellten
das ist die gute seele gehört so firma
das ist eigentlich
der unter trap ist dann ist nach einer
liste oder nachts immer wieder von neuem
anfangen das schiff ist suppe gibt und
natürlich wasser ist oder ob sie mit
enteiser alles zum fsj nick war auch
sozial engagiert er stellt die menschen
ein die es im leben nicht leicht hatten
und von dem er hat sich einiges zum
besseren geräte haben sie ergriffen und
das ist schön dass ich auch linie
familien das post
es war eine gute zeit ein florierender
kleinbetrieb mit herz und seele und
einem chef bei dem man wusste wie er
tickt
[Musik]
heute ist es still geworden in der
werkstatt des erfinders
was ich eigentlich mit ihnen auch stellt
es ist ganz sicher
warum
entlassen musste er seine angestellten
weil aufträge ausblieben und dann verlor
er noch den großteil seines vermögens an
internetbetrügern
standortwechsel sind mit ihrer
mannschaft
bemüht
sondern maximal sieht wilfried er
entwickelte maschinen und produzierte
zulieferteile für großkonzerne bereit
auch privat lief es bei ihm rund fuß
aber glücklich verheiratet mit einer
musikerin aus erster ehe hat er einen
inzwischen erwachsenen sohn
doch mehr weh
was ein zettel
stunde um emotionen mit einem gebäude
von yvonne investiert und natürlich als
unternehmer plus für mitarbeiter und es
ist total wenn du musst ihr wenn ihr
aber sehr es kaputt gegangen ist oder im
büro animod leder tunnel da sie nicht
der hauptstadt oder nacht ist also
lieber tegel wo er meist im schnitt
zwischen
30 bis 50 stunden schaffen und das hat
dann traut man hat frau ist natürlich
denn wie man überstand exil weil wir
können miteinander
unternehmer.de astat abgründig und
tiefgründig vor der zeit der firma nie
so viel
investieren aber es ist ganz logisch ich
hatte ja nie wie ihre partnerin
und das ist ein überragendes endlich
weniger kaputt gegangen ist
moment ist es relativ schwierig
sind stahl sehr naiv eben ganz schlecht
letzten fünf jahren
und aufwärts aber
in einer anderen richtig gut aber
im moment fühle mich gut
ja
es sind ja irgendwas links und rechts
berg spätzeit
und
biographischen in wolfsberg stammt
eigentlich denkt
springt
böses partei
aber wächst das ist
zwischen dem mini art und weise so
andere mir vertraut und sorgt so
und somit natürlich auch komplett
zu hause beim ehepaar nic
die gebürtige holländerin ag nick ist
seit über 50 jahren mit ihrem york
verheiratet im betriebe ist die 86
jährige unter anderem für die
buchhaltung zuständig für mich ist es
auch
lästig denn von allem ich möchte einfach
gern nehmen rechneten er rechtzeitig
bezahlen und auch wenn es selbständig
nicht und im moment überhaupt keine
aufträge hat dann muss ich sagen dass es
keine probleme gibt mit lieferanten oder
sonst so war oder
vsv knopf wurden ja als geldes genannt
worden
das ehepaar hat eine gemeinsame tochter
sie hat mit ihrem vater keinen kontakt
mehr er sei unbelehrbar
das findet auch seine frau
haben sie ihn dann qualvoll
der sache natürlich
aber nicht so schlecht
der rat von anderen
weil er einfach sein kopf durchgesetzt
und einfach mein jahr das große geld
kommt und gibt einfach glaube wir haben
ja genug was sie tun werden was ich
erlebe richtig los aber das werde ich
jetzt weniger schaurig
sind je nach produkt of view das auch
sehr groß
ich bin
manchmal sehr traurig sie das trotzdem
das wieder gemacht habe und immer wieder
gemacht habe und so viel geld eigentlich
eher verschenkt hat
und dass er ist so intelligent und
es muss einfach er sucht sie dass man
einfach nicht aufhören
so sehe ich das
beruhigend das muss jetzt gemacht haben
vielleicht sachen korrigieren aber die
frage gar nicht was ich gemacht
wie kommen sich eigentlich keine
internetbetrug spitze wir haben im
moment vorsichtig sie wenn das angebot
wirklich zu gut ist um eigentlich wenn
sehr hoch mit gewinnversprechen geht
denn nicht dass immer das alarmzeichen
weil die normalen investments die hat
eine der so hoch wie grüne machen und
das ist durch ruß signal unterlagen
rocker seite blühte und wandern auf
vorschusszahlungen zudem mit dass es
egal ist das überhaupt ja das geht der
mann hat wirklich seriös abklären und
vielleicht mal wütend fällig im internet
ist die recherche machen was ich als
führer für ihre mama wie steht das
investment wie stellt sich das da macht
das sing mit barem einigen ihr holz um
den eben abschließen können beurteilen
geld investieren oder nicht
bruno voß er muss mit einem verlust von
mehreren millionen franken leben er
schuldet auch etlichen bekannten geht
weil sie um unterstützung bat die hohen
beträge verwendete fuße um
vorschusszahlungen an die betrüger zu
leisten
begann zurückzogen die hatten immer
kontakt willy sachs ohne die kann hier
ist im royal neue möglichkeiten und
dadurch bliebe mir meine
sozialwohnung monika und die vielen
damals existieren und was man
meisterschaft gemacht dass sie mit neuen
attacken über das problem reden weil mit
den ohne greta helferin idiot aber
verständnis an die praktischen punkte
als er noch ein erfolgreicher
unternehmer war scharten sich viele
leute um ihn das war einmal
da seien sich sehr viele junge
zurückzogen für ganz freundeskreis
vortrag ist die anzeige von willi
also selbst meine eigene sohn hat sich
zurückgezogen der ganze weg der ganze
situation also ja zwei enkel gehen
praktisch leer so
wenigstens einen lichtblick gibt es bei
ihm bruno fischer fand inzwischen eine
stelle als
unternehmensberater
jörg nix sorgen nehmen kein ende nun
muss er auch noch seine werkstatt
aufgeben weil er für sein haus blauäugig
einen vorverkaufs vertrag unterschrieben
hat teil des vertrages war ein darlehen
welches er dringend benötigte doch er
übersah dass er die liegenschaft im
spätherbst 2021 an die neuen besitzer
abtreten muss und was starten konkret
dem vertraut wo sie aus schnepel
vertrauter homburger ich besorge ich
hatte ja vierte mann traut will ich seit
dieser zeit sozialwohnung und wir sind
soziale wohltat muss sie nicht lang
locker hat der vertrag auch nicht
kontrollieren kann unterschreiben die
frau haben sie damit gemacht hat
ziemlich gar nicht da waren sie auch als
verdreifachen die leute sind nehmen
freundlich zu mir bis alles erledigt ist
doch auch wenn ich das zdf sein großes
maß an naivität der geschichte hier mit
so
aber des raums labour minister fest
juristische sachen kümmert sondern alles
entwickelt und jetzt haben wir den
chemiker oder selbst nicht viel kosten
sie werde immer zu ihrem mann stehen
egal was kommen mag sagt akin ich aber
das zusammenleben mit ihrem york fällt
der momentan nicht leicht er habe sich
stark verändert
sich immer mehr ab sondern oder anderen
sieg von ihm ab weil er sich einfach ich
würde sagen total verändert hat dass ich
nicht mehr der gleiche mensch
ungefähren hat er sich dann daran wird
ja dass er einfach nicht mehr
positive lustige menschen ist und das
sehr gereizt ist man muss nur bis sexy
mit pasta flip trumpf
in der garage beginnt der betagte
erfinder mit dem entsorgen seines
lebenswerks das muss alles weg und das
ich habe das selber landschaft und haben
wir dann etwas
sinnvolles machen und jetzt kann man
alles praktisch akteure
der 88-jährige schafft das entsorgen im
alleingang unmöglich aber die zeit läuft
ihm davon
es droht eine zwangsräumung
ein paar tage später drei sammler und
elektronik fachleute machen einen
rundgang in der einst pulsierenden
werkstatt
die große welle lägen in den meisten und
lampen entsprechen machen außerdem ruft
der anfang wo man sich den stammplatz
nick hofft dass ihm die männer ein paar
seiner geräte abkaufen
also wir jetzt auch da mixa werde dann
ist rom ich nehme noch nicht da so was
machen sie dann mit recht vor
der ernsthaft das geht ja schon jetzt
warum ihm
die besucher haben freude an den alten
maschinen
schöne und unverwüstliche apparaturen
seien es aber gebrauchen könne man sie
hierzulande kaum noch
futter
bezogen
es ist ende oktober seine maschinen
wurde er noch immer nicht los mit nick
müsste zu diesem zeitpunkt seine
werkstatt geräumt haben doch sein
kreativer geist kümmert sich um anderes
wie kaufe ich hab so was
dort passiert wenn wir die ruft das dvd
rws sich im café dann ab bildet das
heißt also dass farbstoff vor der kapsel
jeder kampf aber dass ich bis jetzt im
prinzip ja aber das ist schon gehört und
stimmbürger diesen stab dem endlager das
beruf wirksam sind und dass man
mitmachen wenn sachen nicht stimmen aber
sollte sie sich hinter uns mit sohn
kümmert dass wir das endlich ruhe so
schwer dass zwangs grund die ganze
weltoffen ist da bin ich glaube
aber nicht überall antworten
was ihm etwas zeit verschafft ist eine
baustelle rund um sein haus
so glauben die
[Musik]
frage ich habe mich ein lastwagen hof
wehner war das alles gestellt das ist
die ganz das ist auch alles zur doch
haben wir sagen dass auch meine tore
also sagen dass ich die strecke
bis zum heutigen tag fand noch keine
zwangsräumung statt doch weg muss er das
ist ihm klar
und so endet diese geschichte mit der
erkenntnis dass gutgläubige viel
verlieren können geld und vertrauen in
menschen
[Musik]